traversons l'atlantique si vous le
voulez bien aux états unis d'amérique et
bernie sanders le socialiste fait
désormais figure de favori des primaires
démocrates il a rassemblé le plus grand
nombre de voix dans l'iowa dans le new
hampshire et le nevada
cette course en tête a fait exploser au
grand jour la fracture au sein du parti
les démocrates au sein du parti au sein
des démocrates pardon entre les
socialistes d'un côté et les tenants
d'une un discours plus au centre qui
voudrait rassembler largement face à
trump christophe de voogd est-ce que
selon vous donald trump considère
aujourd'hui que bernie sanders est un
candidat sérieux
écoutez je vais être un peu rapide sur
ce sujet parce que justement il ya des
vrais spécialistes sur ce sujet n'a
vraiment moi je suis pas un grand
spécialiste états unis je pense que le
match sanders trump à l'arrondi que
trump le souhaite je ne sais pas si
c'est une posture ou si c'est une
véritable condition de 30
en tout cas moi il me paraît ouvert ce
match sanders trump et pour des raisons
que d'autres peuvent analyser la
question que moi je pose c'est est ce
que ce match aura lieu
je n'en suis pas sûr parce que je ne
pense pas que le parti démocrate soit
ravi de la montée de sanders que les
candidatures modéré mises bout-à-bout
représente beaucoup et que je vois mal
sanders
mais je peux me tromper obtenir une
majorité des délégués majorité absolue
match et soutenir effectivement les
démocrates sont pas trop sont pas très à
l'aise avec bernie sanders est ce que
vous pensez qu'il visait tout faire pour
l'en empêcher
il s'appelait il n'y a pas qu'avec
bernie sanders ce qui est sûr c'est que
trump est en position favorable pour
l'instant il est en position favorable
il ya en 2016 l'élection de trump arrêt
c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
baroque une chose d'ailleurs à laquelle
personne n'a cru y compris dans les
quelques heures qui ont suivi le scrutin
que personne ne l'avait vu venir
et une fois la nouvelle confirmée
percement le monde entier l'opinion
internationale a été sidérée par cela
aujourd'hui quand même sa réélection
paraît assez probable assez probable
mais c'est pas alors je sais
probablement très très incertain mais on
est et ce qu'on observe c'est que en
dépit de toutes les séquences qu'il a
traversés et y compris la dernière c'est
à dire le risque de destitution il a il
est au contraire remontée alors
peut-être que jérôme sainte-marie
dispose de chiffres différents
moi ce que j'ai lu la semaine dernière
faisait état d'un sondage gallup qui
disait qu'il était remonté de 39 à 49 %
donc à un niveau en fait de peu
hilarité relativement inédit à la proche
du scrutin qu'il a en face de lui
effectivement des démocrates qui avec le
caucus de l'iowa ont pas démontré leur
professionnalisme qui sont là très
divisés ils sont encore 12 en piste ce
qui fait que voilà il c'est le principe
d'une primaire il y en a un qui sort
vainqueur mais après ça tu as quand même
fait étriller par par tous ses
concurrents et là ils sont onze à cette
fin ils sont tous assez trier et donc
ils vont être 11 à à passer bernie
sanders sur le grill et puis bernie
sanders
on le voit bien en terme de
renouvellement générationnel ou en terme
de renouvellement programmatique pose
question alors est-il capable derrière
de faire une majorité sur son nom
on voit bien que c'est une certitude
néanmoins et jeu on verra si jérôme
sainte-marie confirme ça moi j'ai vu que
les sondages en fait le dos mais comme
le meilleur adversaire de trump en
termes de capacité à le battre précise
jérôme sainte-marie est ce que vous vous
décortiquer un petit peu l'électorat de
bernie sanders
il se décrit lui comme le seul capable
de galvaniser les jeunes les minorités
les ouvriers alors la première chose
c'est qu'effectivement je suis allé voir
mais les sondages je veux pas non plus
je ne suis pas très bien élection
présidentielle cette année mais enfin
les pour la primaire mais là je tombe
sur un site où effectivement il ya tous
les sondages qui sont publiés je prendre
uniquement les six derniers sondages
quand il fait au mois de février
c'est ils donnent tous bernie sanders
devant notre atout c'est très virtuel
effectivement candidat qui sortira des
primaires sera probablement celle moins
poussée que abîmé et puis il y aura des
phénomènes de scission et c'est au sein
du parti voir au niveau électoral si
mettons au thunder était battu on s'est
beaucoup qui on sait très bien qui a
beaucoup de la 5e je crois des votes à
la primaire c'est en fait d'aider les
fans des délégués du parti donc
effectivement si on était battu c'est
des partisans considéré en plus la
dernière fois que c'est le parti qui a
été déloyal à son égard mais si
inversement ils l'emportent
on voit bien qu'il ya un an il est quand
même n'est pas loin d'un discours
socialiste ce qui aux états unis pose un
petit peu alors justement c'est comme ça
ça qui m'a beaucoup frappé parce que
m'attendais pas à trouver ces chiffres
là je pensais qu'il s'inverse faisait
moins bien que les autres
parmigiani est donc ce site est très
bien fait et les sondeurs américains ont
pas mal de moyens qui peuvent tester
visiblement tout toutes les hypothèses
avec les principaux candidats à la
primaire
et bien c'est le seul avec elizabeth
warren qui l'emporterait à chaque fois
face à trappes
donc il en porte pour l'instant donc là
cet argument massif dans une primaire
là dessus or c'est effectivement un
gosse ya quelqu'un qui à 78,78 qui a eu
une attaque cardiaque il ya quelques
temps au point qu'il a dû produire des
attestations médicales montrant qu'il
était en pleine forme
mais pendant qu'il n'y a pas de
renouvellement générationnel mais un peu
comme mr en ressentant précisément il ya
un renouvellement programmatique qui est
assez qui est assez fort qui même jugé
assez radicales pour les états unis ce
soit en politique étrangère ou un
politique intérieure mais c'est ce que
nous dit chris crise ont répondu il me
dit sanders est beaucoup trop socialiste
pour l'américain moyen
marc landré un commentaire là dessus la
sécurité sociale les universités
gratuite
tout ça c'est trop à gauche du logement
social est-ce que c'est trop à gauche
non plus farid le la change de sender
c'est qu'il est opposé à trump
donc on oppose les extrêmes et on se
compare en vérité c'est pas un vote
d'adhésion c'est un vote d'opposition et
comme trump est très à droite et ne sert
que les électeurs du michigan et daiwa
parce que lui ce que pensent les
français et les parisiens ils sont fous
complètement trump dont il a toujours
dit moi j'ai été élu par les américains
c'est pas pour faire la politique
que veulent que je fasse les français
ouais ou les chinois donc lui il va
flatter son électorat ceux qui votent
pour lui
et donc ce que pensent les
internationaux lé parisien bobo du 11e
ou 17e
il s'en fout complètement novice mathieu
en revanche est en revanche c'est ce qui
est très drôle ces deux rues donc de
comparer cette élection cette primaire
là avec celle des républicains en 2016
parce qu'en vérité saunders jouets
vêtements la même carte 4 up to me
considère comme un guignol quelqu'un d'
extrémistes
ce qui est étrange pour 2016 parmi les
républicains et tout le monde disait
enfin s'il sort vainqueur des primaires
le républicain le soutiendrons pas
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait finalement ils
n'ont pas eu le choix
donc si saunders sort en tête et qu'il
n'y a pas le choix de le soutenir tout
le monde se ralliera comme un seul homme
derrière lui parce que c'est la seule le
seul capable de battre up qui est quand
même pour les gens de gauche socialistes
communistes ou pas aux états unis
l'épouvantail est l'homme à abattre
donc je pense que le match ouvert on est
d'accord match ouvert
je suis est ce qu'il y arrivera on sent
un possible ce soir c'est là que
gergorin dit il est franchement est
aussi est ce qu'il y arrivera on regarde
ça avec nos yeux d'occidentaux ne
européen mais si on était si on se
mettait dans la peau d'un électeur
américain c'est très difficile de se
voir parce que quels sont les prix les
points importants pour un électeur
américains quels sont ces centres de
préoccupation pour l'instant trump il y
répond en grande partie parce que il est
sécurisé il est flat fatras des pas si
populaire que ça quand même faire
attention à ce que je sais bien que les
chiffres ils viennent au bout de quatre
ans et pas le président le plus
impopulaire économies sont pour le
moment bon plus populaire que notre
président mais quand même mais les
chiffres économies sont encore assez bon
ce n'est pas forcément une très mauvaise
nouvelle pour les démocrates et pro
bernie sanders est clair
justement lui sa promesse est en
quelques sortes de rêver comment parler
les dividendes de la paix à l'époque
après la chute du mur de berlin
eh bien là c'est un peu les dividendes
de la croissance en disant regardez ce
pays qui s'enrichit ne autisme ne vous
profite très peu alors cette perception
est très variable aussi on est plein
pour choquer loin de l'univers français
en fonction de l'origine ethnique par
exemple qui a enregistré par les
sondeurs aux états unis là les
différences entre profils très
différents de la différence au jeu
largement supérieure à celle d'obama
bout de quatre ans oui et les
internautes pourront encore plus
critique et les internautes qui nous
regarde bien on leur posait la question
de bernie sanders peut-il battre
donald trump aux élections
présidentielles et une disent non à 70%
citoyen payeur nous disent ander est un
has been il faudrait une autre pointure
façade trump claudius à zut on observe
surtout que l'électorat américain
devient de plus en plus flottant et
babineau conclu les pros trump sont
ravis d'une candidature de bernie
sanders un dernier morceau pierre je
relisais sur le renouvellement
programmatique
quand j'entends le commentaire sur
sanders et un ringard alors ce qu'ils
proposent c'est à dire une autre
politique fiscale pour faire davantage
de redistribution la couverture santé
des universités gratuite du logement
social
ça correspond globalement à par exemple
qu'est ce qu'un pays européens moyens et
est susceptible de faire
en réalité le socialisme c'est en fait
de la social démocratie mais pour la
barre est différente il est l'heure de
rendre ce qu'ils votent appelé
malheureuse mais là c'était merci
débattue ce soir merci infiniment aux
internautes de nous avoir suivi et on se
retrouve demain pour la dernière
émission de la semaine
[Musique]